a prominent belarus opposition leader is
missing after being abducted off a
street in the capital minsk maria
kalitzka nikova who's spoken at many
major rallies
was taken away in a van by unidentified
people
she's been a campaign manager for
opposition politicians and a vocal
supporter
of svetlana takanovskaya who's now in
exile in lithuania
bernard smith is monitoring developments
from neighboring
lithuania bernard just bring us up to
date with what we know about this
alleged abduction
well it's clear that the risk of being
taken off the streets
or arrested in a protest or being thrown
into jail is becoming
an occupational hazard for opposition
leaders
in belarus as well as the hundreds of
thousands of people who are continuing
to protest
four weeks after alexander lukashenko
declared he'd won
the august nine election with eighty
percent of the vote
but over maria nicolesnikova
was according to a witness dragged off
the street she dropped her phone
during the scuffle the phone was picked
up by one of the men that had dragged
her away in the van and the van drove
off
minsk police say they haven't detained
her
but she has not been heard off since
this morning and some of her colleagues
have not been heard off
this morning either select lana chicken
of skyr
her friend and colleague already exiled
here in vilnius
says it looks like an attempt by the
authorities to derail the opposition
uh coordination council and she says uh
lukashenka's regime is engaged in terror
bernard this is the latest in a series
of detentions uh and
of opposition members by the authorities
of course at this stage we still
don't know exactly who it has been that
might have taken them
to take maria but given the
circumstances is there any sense that
the protests are beginning to thin out
or else they are they as strong as they
have always been
sunday's protest from what we were able
to see from the pictures and what we
heard from people on the ground
were as big as they have been in the
last three or four weeks certainly
didn't seem to be any
smaller so if there's been any attempt
at intimidation
it hasn't been particularly successful
so far there was an uptech
uptick in the number of detentions made
i think some 633 according
to the police in mince police in belarus
interior ministry
in belarus arrested nationwide on sunday
and we saw
a greater attempt by security forces to
pick people out
of the protest as they started going
home rather than tr
when that when there were numbers were
thinner on the ground but if anything
the protest numbers have been swelled by
intimidation
tactics but luka shenka is determined
to hang on he's off to moscow in a
couple of days according
to the kremlin he shows no sign of
giving up and he's now reliant
on the patronage of vladimir putin who
has given his support to the status quo
in belarus
and lukashenko will be discussing that
with putin in a few days time
that's bernard smith bringing us up to
date on the situation
in um minsk on that alleged abduction
from
neighboring lithuania barna thanks very
much indeed well veronica cepcalo is a
belarus opposition leader who's a
campaigned alongside maria kolesnikova
she says
it's a typical tactic of lukashenko's
regime to try to intimidate leaders
there is no information hopefully she
was detained for a couple of hours
because
in our country in belarus you know it's
so-called
normal it's not normal but in a good
sense but it's normal when
the people get uh detained without any
explanations
so hopefully she will be uh released as
soon as possible because i really worry
about her
in belarus the entire nation became
leaders itself
if you see the leaders that we see the
leaders everywhere now
in the streets in the students in the
universities uh
in the factories in the plan uh plans
lukashenko regime works this way
every time they see a leader they would
like to isolate this this leader from
the
people from the belarus nation and this
is so-called as i said it's
normal uh in belarus right now but uh
hopefully lukashenko will not be able to
detain
9.5 million people of belarus because
there's
simply there will not be any space in
the prisons but unfortunately this is
how
kashank regime is working now the
protesters will never give up uh as you
see it's been almost one month since the
peaceful protest protests uh started and
we believe for uh the sunna lokashanka
leaves the better for the entire country
for
international communities so to my
opinion we will never give up the
belarus nation
will never give up because there is no
uh like there is no another way for
belarus we want another
president we want a new free elections
and we want all political
uh political uh detainees to be released
as soon as possible so we will fight
until the
very end we believe the belarus nation
believes the russian uh federation will
never
allow any troops on belarus borah or on
belarus territory
and as i said like we will find a fight
until the very end it's always i refer
to the peaceful
protests i refer to the peaceful
demonstrations and
we will fight until lukashenka leaves
belarus until kashanka gives up
gives up his power because like
belarus people do not support fukushima
any longer he has not more than three
percent of the votes now